hi I'm Gary Owen on barstool sports
because I'm awesome if you can install
if you can instantly have one Talent
what would it be to fly okay suit out
and you get a one Talent what would it
be
ah I would think the same I'd like to be
like a really like really good singer
like Marvin Gaye oh my god like step off
a little Duvall who went in a fight and
Navy SEALs brain and the toddler's body
or a toddler's brain and a seals body
I'm gonna go with a toddler's brain in a
seals body cuz if your toddler you can't
really move it was a stupid question who
would you rather have who would you
rather have half your teeth or half your
hair woo half my hair you can wear hats
you ain't got your grill done I grew up
in a trailer park I know about the half
teeth you've been in charge of running
heck the afterlife for people not evil
enough for hell what's the first torture
you designed I think you hang them
upside down and tickle their feet
because air by face pain but I'm taking
was getting tickled for eternity oh my
god
would you rather never have sex again
and never eat a favorite food again
never eat a favorite food well my
favorite food is
gluten-free you get offered a billion
dollars to never leave the state of Ohio
do you take it in a second in a second
baby ballast out bring a beach how build
a beach who is a celebrity most want to
see in a sex tape Pam Grier from the 70s
when she was Foxy Brown 1970s Pam Grier
you can have one thing free for the rest
of your life what do you choose dang
that's a good one one thing free for the
rest of your life what do you choose
mortgage payments if every time you
finish the sex song if every time you
you finished sex a song played which
song would you want it to be [ __ ]
better have my money
who wins in a street fight Allen I ever
sent her yeah Ming I know this is crazy
we'll go Allen Iverson his car deal is
good man yeah he moving much so I didn't
think element Allen's got some hood in
them too I got Allen Iverson and upset
would you [ __ ] the ugliest teacher you
ever had to [ __ ] ever had had to [ __ ]
the hottest heater you guys need some
commas and periods in this would you
[ __ ] the August heat you never had to
[ __ ] the huh no no dude no mrs. Everly
Wow
I couldn't get I couldn't do it see 85
she had it she's got it she had me she's
got to be dead like I had her in like
third second great oh no I've never
really had a superhot teacher though
honestly I never had a teacher I was
like whoa she's a stun up now now stick
with the hand